what's good how you guys doing can I get
some noise please just a little bit hey
hey yo first of all welcome to bleach
report not bad right hope you guys enjoy
the food got some drinks get all of that
I have the esteemed pleasure of enjoying
and welcoming you guys to the stick to
football live podcast taping brought to
you by manscaped and I'm so happy you're
here and the reason you're here is for
two dudes that are good friends of mine
and their badass [ __ ] ballers
and I just cursed cuz I looked around I
didn't see any [ __ ] kids can I get a
round of applause please for Matt Miller
and Connor Rodgers what's up guys
thank you for coming out a lot of guys
actually wow there's there are two girls
out how to do its lotta dudes yeah
that's what we expected as Lefko said
thanks to our sponsors a man scape for
throwing this you guys who are loyal
listeners to stick to football know that
one of our favorite things to do is to
get out to meet you guys to hang out so
thank you for coming out we have a
special guest who will be joining us in
about 10 minutes a local tree the New
York Giants make some noise for him give
it up for Alec so we're gonna do a
normal stick to football show tonight
Connor and I are gonna talk about what's
going on around the league right now
we're gonna interview Alec and then you
guys get to ask questions with your
draft on draft questions so this will be
if you're a listener or be familiar to
you right kick this thing off alright
here we go we'll jump right in the
biggest news of the day my Kansas City
Chiefs make the trade to get Frank Clark
from the Seattle Seahawks Connor and
I've been talking about it all day we've
been talking about it for months like
that we thought this trade could happen
especially once the Russell Wilson deal
got done we felt like it was very likely
that this was going to happen I know I'm
excited about it but I expect you to be
the voice of reason here now
I think it's one of those rare trades
where both sides of wind when you look
at it Seattle was coming into staffed
for picks so something we say on every
single show is you need more giraffe
capital they're not a rebuilding team
they just gave Russell Wilson a lot of
money but still when you get back up
first in a second for a guy they were
not gonna give him that 63 million
dollars guaranteed and he was not gonna
show up to camp on the franchise tag
they made that very clear early on when
you look at Kansas City
I mean you ship D Ford out because of a
scheme change that's a big loss for them
so when it comes down to it they need to
add a pass rusher they're in win now
mode you look at Pat mahomes there I
mean this is a team that wants to be
back in the agency championship game
guys pretty good so Matt has said this
on every single show Veatch is gonna be
one of the most aggressive general
managers in football and he continues to
prove that with this deal yeah and I
think from the the Kansas City
perspective and I know you guys are
probably hearing about Kansas City about
it this this is one of those moves that
while you have a quarterback who's still
on a rookie wage scale deal you have to
be aggressive look at what the Rams did
with Jared Goff on a similar deal you
can pay Aaron Donald and go get Marcus
Peters and Aqib Talib an endemic ensue
and try to build a team that can close
that gap and they got close they almost
made it almost took down the New England
Patriots
I think the Chiefs are trying to do a
similar thing where okay I think Frank
Clark is a better player than Dee Ford
so you made an upgrade there and yes it
cost money but as we always say the
salary cap is fake it doesn't matter
that you're gonna have to pay him sixty
three million guaranteed because the cap
will go up again next year and then
there's a new CBA that's coming into
play where the players might get a
bigger piece of the pie so I think this
is smart forecasting not just by Veatch
and Andy Reid but by Clark Hunt by
ownership of the Chiefs to say we're not
worried about the salary cap we can
still pay Chris Jones and and be this
dominant team who like right now I think
they have one the best one-two punches
in the NFL on defense yeah and I think
something that a lot of people are
missing with Frank Clark is last year he
was one of the best pass rushers in all
of football this is he got DeMarcus
Lawrence money because a lot of people
around the league believe he'll have a
Lawrence impact so I think when you look
at how does this change the draft when
it comes down to it Kansas City was a
team they've been calling to look to
move up
they've been aggressive they wanted to
get one of the
five top six pass rushers instead they
get a guy Pro ready goes back to the
winning window and a guy that they felt
like they could pay for the future that
fits the scheme not just the pass rusher
but a guy that could defend the run
let's take this back to the draft Connor
the Seahawks like you said only had four
picks coming into this week now they add
pick number 29 overall and they get they
swap third-round pick so you're picking
a little bit later in round three but
they add a 2020 second-round pick I have
a final seven or a mock draft coming out
Thursday morning I'll be nice enough and
spoil it for you I think they can get
Cleveland Farrell at 21 and I think they
can get Lonnie Johnson at 29 and fill
those two biggest needs that they have
if we don't see them trade back so I
think the draft implications for Seattle
my personal belief is you're overvaluing
picks instead of a proven player but if
you're worried about the cap if you're
worried about giving Frank Clark that
money now you have the ammo and a lot of
flexibility really because they can move
back from 21 they could sell 29 but I
think they can walk away with two
starters and they this is a team that
reloaded really well yes last year on
the fly we thought there were gonna be a
bad team last year and they didn't get
impact from their first-round pick
Rashad pinning so now they can reload a
little bit on the go I think to put a
ball in this mat the one thing I have to
ask you is is this enough for Kansas
City because now you're without a lot of
ammo in this draft yes they had extra
day two picks to work with but what
people want to know at the end of the
day is is this enough to get over the
hump of the New England Patriots I I
think it is because I think the hope is
that you see development from a Homes in
year two and a lot of people watch
better get again a sophomore slump right
but there were some there were five or
six touchdowns left on the field last
year so I think it is enough but like
you said they have picks 61-63 and now I
believe they have 84 overall in round
three and Brett Beach has been
aggressive I think he has an iffy track
record right now as a drafter especially
with just that really one class we
haven't seen a big dividend yet but they
have to hit those three picks if they're
gonna catch New England who by the way
has 12 picks in this draft well now to
keep it moving because everyone's tired
and talking about the Chiefs back to the
top of the draft to the Chiefs there's
been a lot of talk this week will Kyler
Murray actually be the number one pick I
know CBS I believe alerted that he won't
yeah yeah with that reaction is has
anything changed since January no no did
you want more than that I don't think
anything's changed I understand that
this time of year we all feel pressure
to send off that fire tweet that's gonna
get all these likes and retweets I feel
that way too sometimes like man I wish I
had something to put out there because
I'm I would love for your to report this
right but you don't want to just make
something up or get blatantly used by a
team I've been burned before I was
telling this story on Adam left coast
podcast comes out tomorrow you guys want
to check that out like I got burnt last
year by a team who said hey our coaches
want this player we might we might draft
him they didn't it made me look stupid
but that was real information that a
team gave me I don't doubt that someone
told Pete Prisco that the Cardinals
dreamed up this Kyler Marie situation to
sell season tickets but that's like
that's that's like the draft-day movie
dumb like that doesn't happen
teams NFL teams aren't struggling to
sell tickets they're like $300 a pop I
don't think you have to lie and say we
might take Kyler Murray while in the
meantime we're pissing off our very
thin-skinned quarterback last year yeah
I just don't think it's worth it that
was the next thing I was gonna lead to
you don't let all of this go on if you
feel that you know you're not gonna lead
Josh Rosen astray for no reason local
girlfriend was insecure would you flirt
with another girl for three months right
in front of her no I I like my life
thank you right no why would you do that
that's all they're doing man so no I
don't think anything change regardless
of what CBS says I do believe it'll be
Cuyler Murray
then Nick Bosa and then it's gonna get
weird it's real interesting my New York
Jets so when it comes down to it
everybody knows the Jets want to trade
this pick it's no secret I think there's
been a lot of buzz around whether it's
Washington don't get your hopes up for
the Giants they don't ever do business
if the Jets stay at three it's weird to
say get stuck like the number three pick
is a great pick you don't want to say
get stuck because you get a good player
there what is your gut feeling right now
my gut is they OD line and I know that
we've said Josh Allen for a long time
because they missed on Anthony barn free
agency and it just makes sense right to
fill a gap with the guy that burned you
that you had a deal done with and he
backed out
I do think it'll be defensive line and
maybe I'm over connecting some dots here
with Gregg Williams and the defense that
he wants to run with the idea that
Leonard Williams is gonna be free agent
very soon so why not just go best player
available and take Quintin Williams who
is the top guy on my board your favorite
player and Oliver makes sense because
you want interior pressure look at the
playoffs I think Melo said this on mock
draft Monday the top three sackers in
the NFL last year were interior
defensive linemen so why not try to get
your Chris Jones or your JJ Watt
Fletcher Fletcher Cox
yeah Erin Donald is the dream but why
not get an interior player who everyone
wants to talk about three four or four
three and you're in sub package sixty
seventy percent of the time now anyway
so get someone who can impact the game
from a three technique so my follow-up
to that is what kind of voice in the
drafter room if you're the Raiders
everybody was sent home but in the Jets
traf room first year defensive
coordinator there I know he's been
successful everywhere in the past does
Greg Williams have I think you if you're
Greg Williams you have to hope that
you've spent the last three months
building a relationship with someone in
that front office whether it's Mike
mckagan or Brian heimerdinger or
whomever in the stacking order you have
to hope that you've made the connection
with one of those guys to plead your
case to say okay if if we can't trade
out please get me this player because
that that does happen you coaches often
and they will be more involved in the
draft process for some teams then the
scouts they'll have a chance to to
profess how important a player is so
before we move on to the Oakland Raiders
let's talk about that trade out scenario
because is there a point in this draft
where you feel like you can't move
beyond that point is it 15 with
Washington I do think it's 15 if your
goal is to get an edge rusher if you
have identified and you have to do that
with a trade you have to identify okay
if we move back to 15 we have that many
players that we like so I think 15 is
the breaking point because you could
probably still get Brian burns and fill
your edge rusher need there's a chance
you can maybe get Christian Wilkins if
you want to go for that defensive tackle
but it takes two to tango right and I
think that's where the Jets are having
trouble so where the lines are having
trouble is there are teams that want to
trade up like the Houston Texans
but getting someone to come up with that
far is where we're stuck right now which
is a perfect segue to why the
eaters are right now rumored to want
every player in the NFL Draft every
single person I said last night
it's no secret they love Quinton
Williams they love Devon white some will
tell you they love that Oliver so this
goes on and on which is a great job by
Oakland number really this is what you
want is that people are connecting dots
everywhere it's almost like their GM has
media experience and knows how to play
this game right so I love Mike and he's
doing a great job of controlling this
process he must be a big game of Thrones
fan because he's owning the politics of
the draft right now like let's move this
piece and oh wait I'm gonna call this
guy and tell him like mayor's probably
won like hey somebody call Connor Rogers
and say that we're gonna take joint
assets well I got fooled I know I'm just
I'm sticking by I hope they take him I
really do because that's the part of the
process we discussed earlier sometimes
you know people think you get fooled and
sometimes it's not the case the coaches
actually might like the player and they
might not win that I'll back you up on
that man signs off on brakes I've heard
a lot that there are people in Oakland
that like Dwayne Haskins just like there
listen Jeremy Bates last year like Josh
Allen the Jets didn't take Josh Allen
doesn't mean Jeremy Bates didn't like
him and didn't value where's Jeremy
Bates now I don't even know yeah it's
probably on a beach somewhere climbing
mountains yeah so it's important to you
know like you're told something and it's
from a credible person it could be the
offensive coordinator the Jets doesn't
mean that's who they're take so I think
the Raiders will take the best of those
- you said Quintin Williams or Devon
white and then the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
are a fascinating team Bruce Arians
basically came out today and said we're
not trading there are five or 60 elite
players in this class so they're
positioned well I think to take whomever
Oakland doesn't if the Raiders take
Quentin bucks take Devon white if the
Raiders take Devon white Bucks take
Quinton or a Tolliver ship Gerald McCoy
out of town and just go about their day
so with them being one of the easiest
teams
what's something in the top ten maybe
top 15 including a trade up that not
would surprise you but would surprise
everyone else are we sleeping on
Cincinnati being in this picture well I
think we're sleeping on Cincinnati being
a team that could trade for a
quarterback trade up to get their
quarterback Detroit it's no secret
Detroit one's out at eight so if you
need to get ahead of the Denver Broncos
that that's the spot you're probably
coming to I wouldn't get you
it gets you Daniel Jones which I know
you hate but it could get you Daniel
so I think that's that's the most
fascinating aspect it seems like the
teams at the end of round one are okay
like the Chargers feel like they could
probably trade for Josh Rosen they're
gonna be okay
the Patriots don't feel sense of urgency
because Tom Brady is God so he's gonna
play for four more years and if you
drafted someone they're probably not
gonna overlap as much as you would like
so I think Cincinnati is a wild card in
this in this draft you know Jacksonville
is - for a long time we've just said TJ
hawk and senator JaJuan Taylor I mean I
wouldn't be shocked if they took DK
Metcalfe I wouldn't be shocked if they
took rashon Gary they could really do
anything and it wouldn't it wouldn't be
a huge surprise at this point another
thing to wrap up around the league how
much does Gary's latest reported injury
affect his stock yeah I think it will
hurt him a little bit it's not like a
Harold Landry last year where he fell to
the second round
but that labral tear everyone believes
that he can play through it it's it's
more of a what is his pain tolerance if
he can play through it then they're
gonna let him you know you can JJ Watt
stun it you can you can brace that thing
up and go through it so shouldn't impact
him a lot but Conner I'm excited to
bring out our guests New York Giants
linebacker Alec Ogletree guys make some
noise for our guests
all right awesome
welcome to stick the football man we
appreciate you coming out appreciate you
having me man
awesome we've been catching up backstage
talking I think we actually just gave
you all our questions earlier today yeah
this is a rerun for sure we wanted to
get you warmed up I'm sure everyone here
wants to know
the burning question are you guys gonna
take a quarterback at 6 or 17 cuz they
tell you that right yeah I mean
gentlemen government just told me today
no I don't know honestly I mean we find
out really just like how you guys find
out of me is look on TV and they're like
oh we drive to this guy so and that's
how trees go down and all that stuff go
down so I mean it's they definitely keep
it pretty tight as far as like what
they're gonna do I mean but you know I
hope that we just dropped guys that you
know are gonna come in and help us win
games I mean you know of course we don't
have a lot of the hoop lot going on
right now but nobody's really backing on
this but you know I definitely think
we're gonna get some guys that you know
come in and help us win a lot of games
this year so so being one of the
veterans left on the defense does that
change your mindset at all knowing that
you might have a new face of the
franchise when you take a quarterback
that's how everyone's bill does or a
pass rusher in the front seven that you
want to bring along does it change
anything anything the way you go about
your business no it doesn't change
anything for me I mean my job is to come
in and you know help the guys get better
and you know lead the defense and you
know I take that responsibility
you know wholeheartedly and and you know
I'm thankful for the opportunity so you
know for me I'm gonna go out there and
do my get my best game all every single
day to the gods to help them get better
and you know hopefully that translate
into winning games you mentioned the
defense and one thing that a lot of us
so-called experts have thought this year
is that this transition to maybe a new
defensive scheme could have maybe it's
why Olivier Vernon is gone maybe it's
why I landed Collins wasn't a priority
how much do you look at that and say
like okay you might be changing to a
different defense how much does that
affect you
in both styles so you know for the thing
is is having the commodity of the Gods
the communication from each level that's
what really makes a good defense I mean
everybody has scheme you could get a
three four four three I think what best
brains to the table is is it's a great
asset for us and the type of gods that
we have in there you know as far as the
OTAs going right now and you will see
what we're doing the drop into Gaza they
bring in but you know his defense is an
attacking style type defense it brings a
lot of pressure it creates confusion for
the offense and you know you put guys in
the right position I mean like I said
but you have to have everybody buying
into the to the same culture or I mean
whatever coach is preaching to us and
you have to you have to buy into that to
get guys to go out there and play well I
mean that to me that's what it comes
down to to being a great defense and you
know I can say everybody has scheme you
see each year one defense is a three for
the next defense is a 4-3 so it really
doesn't matter to scheme but we were
joking before the show you know you
played at Georgia then you're on the
west coast now you're over here in New
York how does that move man has there
been anything that surprised you here or
at the end of the day is it just
football I mean still just football it's
been a a definitely a journey I mean
like I said we started in Georgia and
then moved to the West Midwest and then
out to the west coast so and now here
loud definitely is it's two totally
different you know vibes that going from
here to LA but you know we since we've
got here we've had nothing but a good
experience on had to adjust to the
weather for sure you know I can't I was
I can't beat the weather in LA but as
far as being here I mean I'm I was so
happy to come to this to this division
because I'm seeing it from afar and know
how that each franchise is you know the
fans loved it franchising and
there's no doubt about it and for me
that's probably the closest thing I've
had since being at Georgia you know it
was pretty pretty tough to the first
couple years and well all my years in
st. Louis and then the first year in LA
- my last year that we we got on a
winning streak so you know we can get a
lot of love like that but you know here
the fans are through it through so what
is your favorite Jeff Fisher story
because I mean I don't want to hear any
eight and a [ __ ] you know is that
wasn't that his famous quote like that
was yes so I know we were talking to you
for like fish has a bad reputation among
fans like everyone a football loves the
guy so maybe you can be the voice of
reason and like turn these people around
a little bit I mean fish is a is a is a
player's coach I mean you guys anybody
around the league that has ever played
for fish they'll tell you the exact same
thing I mean take care of the guys he's
he's about he's about winning for and
foremost I mean eighteen eighty he's he
meant that and that's true you know but
yeah the same time you had you have to I
guess he's the fall guy for that I mean
we we the ones that go out there and
play but you know I definitely love
playing for fish I mean he dropped to me
so you know always had that respect for
me and appreciate his you know him in
the Rams for taking me and let me living
my dream but I see a good story let's
see I don't know if I remember that uh
fight we had with the Cowboys like I
forgot what year were there when I dare
and basically like he was like he didn't
tell us the fight and say that I would
say that he did tell us a fight all the
fight but as the days that we was out
there and it kind of kept going you know
a base was like you know don't take no
[ __ ]
and me we finish that get finished that
uh that practices whatever came back in
this enjoy he had beers and all kind of
stuff going on her so it was it was it
was a good time Roger Goodell is already
adventure getting that right now for
sure he's still investigating that all
right simple one for you girly or say
Kwan oh man well you know I'm a die-hard
Georgia Bulldogs you know he's
definitely my God for sure but say
corners man he's unbelievable man since
the day he came in you could tell he's
just a different type of God and that's
the same with Todd I mean I tell people
when I first came to Georgia like that's
what he did talk like it's hard you see
now he did not talk I was like dude a
mute or something then the first game he
got in there I mean broke a hundred yard
kickoff return and like the next the
next play next time he got the ball he
scored again like and it dude special
too
and so you know for when I was in st.
Louis we drive to him and I was with one
of my teammates Michael Broca's and I'm
like so he's driving I was like so hyped
for me and whatever then and uh you know
I know he was gonna be a great a great
asset for us and you know we dropped to
say corn and the moment he came in you
could tell he's just different I mean he
the question he's asked you could tell
he's he doesn't think as a rookie he
already thinks is like he's been in the
league for like three or four years
already and he wants to get better
he's trying to be the best and you could
tell the way he worked when he asked
questions is high he's attentive in
meetings and you know he asked me like
so if I step like this what are you
looking at you know so like I say he's
definitely gonna be you know a great
back in this league with someone that
talented do you pretty much know right
away like from the first practice that
they're different just rare yeah I mean
I tried to guard him a couple of times
he like I was made me fall
[Laughter]
they're recognizable so you're picking
on the vet right now but no I mean he's
a great competitor and uh you know I'm
definitely glad he's on my team for sure
speaking of someone not on your team
though are you a little disappointed
that you don't get to put a shot on
Odell running a slant route because you
guys don't play each other this year we
well what was he like
just just us three talking nobody else I
hear this all right no man I know I know
he'd get a lot of bad rep but you know
he was a great guy for us um when I
first got traded to the Giants he was
first person to contact me and welcome
you to the team so you know that spoke
volumes to me for him to be able to
reach out to me even when I passed
history which I mean I'm sure some of
you guys know about it but you know we
squashed all that or whatever and you
know Kevin movements I've seen her
plenty of times before then before I got
traded but you know I say was the one
the first guys to welcome into the team
you know he came in and worked just like
everybody else he he did his job and he
did it well it was a reason why he's one
of the best receivers in the league so
you know I definitely wish him luck over
in Cleveland and you know if we get a
chance to play them I hope he doesn't do
too much against us just you know let us
get a couple picks and hold them to on
the 50 yards who's the biggest [ __ ]
talker left on the Giants right now hmm
my gut tells me it's not you know it's
not it's not me I don't really talk too
much [ __ ] unless somebody's talking to
me but I secretly hope it's Eli like I
just want like he's actually like yeah
like [ __ ] people yeah that'd be
great
that's not it's not even I roll
no Jack Ryder is not it either
I haven't seen him play yet but just
being at the fight with him this past
weekend Jabril definitely he's a guy
that was high in it oh yeah now he's
definitely what this is for sure kind of
underrated pick cuz you think like when
you have rabbit out there and he's so a
nerd
he's on the island by itself like this
so he only really talked to the receiver
yeah I mean he I'm sure he does he
definitely does he's talking to the
receivers without a doubt but you know I
know the Jay Briscoe being at boxing
with us and all that stuff and like I
said just being at the fight with him
this past weekend and saying how he was
just so energetic about the fight you
know of course he had one of his friends
fighting too but I could definitely see
him stirring the pot a little bit when
the schedule came out was there one game
that you're like all right that's the
one I'm looking forward to the most
the first one yeah that first yeah sure
yeah in the hole right just get it over
with first play I mean I ain't saying
I'd be the first place but you know we
could we could we can do what we got we
need to do you know at a time when we
meet you know we opened up with a
division game is you know no better team
to open up with and Dallas so definitely
excited about that one for sure all
right man something we do on every
episode of stick football is we take
questions from our listener so you're
down answers with questions to them down
all right we call it draft on draft
which normally we have a couple beers
and we do it but you guys can have some
force instead so our live audience will
be asking some questions so Jesse one
raised their hand
let's have a question there we go I'm a
big fan my name is Antonio I got a quick
question to you do you want it will you
rather play zone or man and if you like
playing each one of those like do you
request the coach to hey can you calm or
zone or more man for you I really it
really kind of depends on you know which
team we're playing you know some teams
they run a lot of man beating routes and
you know they try to it's better to play
zone against them just because of the
scheme that they run so it really just
depends on which team were playing and
you know how good their back is or tied
in or whoever it is you know it may not
favor a matchup that we like so you know
it just depends on it like I said the
scheme that we play who you playing
against all right we got another one
here we go you can stand up if you want
to man so we see you hey look I'm a Jets
fan
do you enjoy
[Applause]
do you enjoy it in Jenkins have a bet on
this one on this season's game Jordan
Jenkins yeah no I want to bet with me
man anyway you got take it easy the Jets
a Mets fan that's all right yeah and and
before we get to our next question I
want to remind everybody that Thursday
Friday and Saturday we're gonna be
streaming our coverage of the draft live
on the BR app Twitter and YouTube so
forget NFL network in the ESPN cuz it's
boring and they go to commercial and we
don't they don't live is that it's free
it'd be me Connor left Co day 3 Melo
will join us so if y'all want like real
coverage of the draft we'll take care of
you don't worry
Melo's teaching right now he'll be here
soon hey guys thanks for doing this
number one Alec I am a bulldog as well
so go dogs yeah my son wanted me to ask
you this question what's your favorite
memory is a Georgia Bulldog my favorite
memory as a Georgia Bulldog was
definitely in the SEC championship game
against Alabama and you know I was able
to return a block field goal to that
fourth touchdown and because my wife
went to Alabama so I try to throw that
on her face a couple of times but you
know she she still has the upper hand on
me right now just because you know they
want but that's definitely one of my
favorite memories of playing at Georgia
extra set of the event guys my name is
Ike obviously a Pats fan but I would
just show the rings man you're fine
right exactly with the outstanding
performance that JJ our Sega Whiteside
had at his pro day do you guys think he
goes in the first round so I don't think
he will I wouldn't be surprised to be as
the top 50 pick I think you have to be
careful with pro days to like when a guy
you know you don't have a combine time
or when the combine time a pro day are
so drastically different I mean like I
would want to measure that track like
he's at 38 yards there's a 40 yards I
mean did you run it your Proterra
combine I did both yeah was it a lot
faster the pro day yeah yeah
it always is so you have to take it with
a grain of salt he's a good receiver
we've had a good show guys he's a good
guy but man yeah I think he's a round 2
player I think they pick guys who didn't
want to run fast at the combine and
versus Prodi
oh the clocks rigged I think so
something's going on uh we have to do a
consumer episode with you on yeah you're
not player who said that to us either so
Alec Giants fan there you go is there
anyone the team that you could beat in a
race that we wouldn't guess hmm it's a
good question you got to be careful
there's politics at play here too I feel
like I'm gonna be Evan oh really I think
I could
I seen him get caught water safety one
time and I thought he was gonna score it
and he got a call like and so that gave
me some hope right there I've been
together I know first day is kind of
where all the excitement is but is there
any interior offensive lineman you like
late day to early day 3 and Matt maybe
somebody for the 49ers play right guard
yeah I'm not a 49ers fan anymore have
you heard that so it's also full of [ __ ]
you know I think the run on offensive
line that's gonna happen in the top 50
which is gonna is gonna be depleted you
know guys that we thought would be day 2
like Chris Lidstrom and Eric McCoy are
getting pushed up because there's not
good depth in those classes so you
almost have to start looking at tackles
like Caleb McGarry Dalton Reisner
Michael dieter guys who can maybe play
multiple positions just because we know
where the strengths of the draft are in
teams due to so now we're seeing that
happen I think Michael dieter from
Wisconsin to be a plug-and-play right
guard but after that like you might be
better off taking a like a small school
flier late on day three that you can
develop instead of reaching for someone
that's not a great a great value this
reminds me to ask you how scary is will
Hernandez he's he's definitely a bull
for sure he's the first his first weeks
there he and
yeah couple couple times what a goddess
that's just as big as him and just as
much of a bull as him so you know he
definitely has a mean streak in oh man
you know I say he's not somebody you
want to run into for sure it's used to
wear the like crop top mesh jersey and
practice because he did at the Senior
Bowl and we were like okay I respect
that you're a big guy and you were in
the crowd um no I coach coach doesn't
really allowed us to do stuff like that
so yeah you know he wants to see your
number and see your name and stuff like
that son hey Alec as a bear fan I want
to ask what do you see pre-snap on that
uh it was at the second play from
scrimmage where I saw scrimmage when I
picked off chase Daniel like well he was
looking right at me I was on the line of
scrimmage and he snapped the ball and I
look at my direction like some kind of
way I jumped up and was able to catch
the ball so you know I you know I think
you know good hands and you know I
appreciate him throwing it to me Daniel
you know I like right over here just
want to say for one really want to give
you a huge shout out for the career
you've had so far you know being a
professional and being so productive man
it's been fun watching you throughout
the years and I have a draft question
for two of the best guys I know in this
business when it comes to doing this I
had a chance to speak with Connor about
my Colts in her interview and you know
if the draft coming up soon
Chris Ballard his name has been involved
with a few teams and the question that
I've had because a few people have
thought about this is the fact that is
our ballad and the Colts were they
involved in some of these rumors and
deals because they were actually
interested or is it because Ballard is
typically trying to think ahead and
drive up value for whatever the case may
be
I think both by honestly both and I
think that even goes back to like we
heard the cream hunt stuff first right
and it's like sometimes people just
connect dots because Ballard is
aggressive and maybe he's not gonna put
as much stock into like in Indy you can
handle cream huh a lot differently than
you
here or in LA you know it's so you think
about okay where can someone go that
they would get a second chance
I think ballard has that reputation but
I also think that like this is such a
cliche but like Ballard's plant chests
and like guys are just playing checkers
right and so look at what they did last
year they drafted to all pros it's hard
to be an all-pro rookie it's [ __ ]
impossible to have two of them and they
did it last year so and then I think
this year look where they're positioned
at 26 and they're back on the clock at
34
like they're just outsmarting people
right now with value he's borrowing some
of like what Belichick is done and
letting free agents walk to get calm
picks and there they're just set up for
success and it does help when you have
Andrew Luck that makes you job a little
bit easier but they're doing a really
good job there I mean yeah it's one of
the best front office's in the NFL if
not the best front office and I think
one thing he does so well is they want
everything to be internal they want to
draft their own guys pay their own guys
yeah they went out and got Justin
Houston that was late into free agency
that's wave to wave three so I think
when you look at Ballard and the Colts
in general they're actually one of the
most slept on teams heading into this
season I think they've done just a good
job is the Browns in yeah and don't get
any of the hype I think they've done
almost as good a job as to the Chiefs so
when you look at that front office it's
a special group and I think they they
are the type of team where like you hear
their name attached to the Frank Clarke
rumors but in than today they're just
checking in on everything so you got to
be careful how much external interest
there actually is hi my name is Ali
Siddiqui thank you so much for being
here Alec I'm a Geoff fan so I have to
ask the jet question through it um so I
know you're like in love without Oliver
and I've read about the guy I've heard
about the guy but like the more I keep
hearing about quitting Williams they
keep talking about like how he's like
101 like you won't see a player like
this again so like in like the situation
that we're in at number three what would
you rather do would you rather have
Quinn and Williams at three or would you
rather trade down get a Dolliver a
little bit later left go show tomorrow
now but in a perfect world do you do
trade down because the Jets don't have a
second round pick they have a lot of
holes to fill I think with I think what
people are missing is that ed and Quinn
and while they're listed as defensive
tackles in this draft they're different
players ed went to Houston and they
asked them to play nose tackle and he
was playing out about 270 pounds I know
he got up to 280
seven for the combine 281 for the pro
day but you know it's not fake we it's
just that's not what he played at last
year so you look at a guy like it he can
play on the outside and a pinch if he
needs to we can kick inside on passing
downs Quinton is someone that's gonna
live as a three tech that's simply how
it is so Jets are an interesting
situation I mean you paid Henry Anderson
you have Leonard Williams so it feels
like a couple years ago all over again
when they had Moe Wilkerson Sheldon
Richardson you know they had a log jam
along that defensive line so when it
comes down to it the trade down is the
best option
I'm just not a believer they'll find a
partner to do it hey guys thank you for
doing this my name is Justin Alec I want
to ask what's the weirdest question you
got the NFL Draft I don't remember I
honestly don't remember I will tell you
that I met with the Saints and the D
coordinated what's his name Greg
Williams
no it wasn't great it was no it was no
his name was like Joe's not Joe Vitt
wasn't Steve Joe Vitt till these with
the Jets now be scared I think it's
great I think those whom the short guy
yeah I've heard he erupts in interviews
yeah he like cussed me I don't feel bad
you know like like like dog cuz me like
like yeah don't say nothing
yeah every time I try to tell so he was
like cubby y'all play and I you know
meet yes sir like I couldn't say
anything that was I was a that was about
one of the crazies interviews I had I
was I like this guy's hat it says make
football violent again oh that's what is
defense this year but my question you
Alec is big Giants fan you got some
young talent BJ Hill
Lorenzo Carter Georgia guy big fan of
what are some guys that you think you'd
want to play with that are in the draft
right now on defense as part as
bachelors defense and who do you guys
think that they're gonna target at six
or 17 if at all um well I mean I
I don't really like to say it's kind of
hard for me to say I want to play with
this guy from the drive for whatever I
mean if we got someone on defense you
know I'm I'm banking on them bringing in
guys that has you know high character
and and they want to be here to win
games and you know they're about going
110 percent each and every play and you
know giving them all for the teammates
and so you know if we could find a guy
like that it doesn't matter if they
played defense online linebacker or the
safety or secondary position you know we
just we want somebody in that wants to
win and wants to be great and you know
help us win a lot of games and I think
to your question about six and 17 you
know it's everything I've heard is that
it sticks they want a pass rusher and I
think you look at Dave kettlemans you
know history and Carolina even back when
he was with the Giants before he
prioritizes a line and D line last year
they got will in a second Peyton a
solder it makes sense to this year you
would go with the pass rushers Josh
Allen could be there depending on what
Connors Jets do ed Oliver could be there
and then it's 17 I mean it's hard to
overlook the idea that it would be a
quarterback they've mentioned wanting
that situation like Kansas City you want
someone to sit behind the veteran so
whether it's drew lock or Daniel Jones
or Dwayne Hoskins not danger whether
it's drew long asking you know like I
think that that's the ideal situation
for them and then you know to come back
around to with an early pick and it you
know maybe try to plug in another one of
those holes I mean I think you have to
Wayne Haskins is there at six you take
them and you don't look back it's not
rocket science for me take the
quarterback if he needs to sit because
he was a one-year starter
let him sit 17 there will be somebody
really good left on the board from this
defensive group of guys that have round
one grades
whether it's Montez sweat who might be
sliding burns Cleveland Farrell's
another guy that fits there's a lot of
guys in that group so I actually think
the Giants are positioned well I think
they've done a good job
smoke screening everyone with all this
talk and you know maybe their
quarterback of the future just falls
right into their lap at that top pick I
thought you said their time he was a
linebacker right and then we said like
yeah a middle linebacker know that one
you know what's that I just mastered it
was almost spaced out all right we got
we got a couple dip time for a couple
more two more long time no see
yeah what's a four so for all three of
you I don't care if you've seen them or
not
Riley really or me Cole Hardman Riley
rip yeah I think I think he has I think
he has more of like the actual like
attributes of like I received I know
Niko's yeah and he's more of a track guy
but if I had my pick I would definitely
take Riley I've seen his brother play in
Atlanta he's pretty nice so I'm gonna
cheat Clayton and say it depends on what
team like because for a lot of teams
like Riley's gonna be a very good route
runner he's a good possession receiver
but like if I could put me Cole on the
Rams like okay that'd be fun like I
would do that because they would know
how to use him utilize his speed
Patriots you know there's just the right
teams would finding the waste game the
ball B he's not wrong
yeah yeah I mean the Georgia guys right
right I mean they're fantastic two
totally different players I like me Cole
a lot just because of his speed I think
he could be even more productive at the
next level in an offense that uses them
vertically but Riley's gonna be a really
good player for a really long time
all right we got one more and it's a
Jets fan
hey she's getting weaker I see
question for Connor and Matt how high
was go Brent when he compared Daniel
Jones to Peyton Manning man no comment I
don't know what I I will say this and I
know this is like a PC answer I respect
Gil Brandt a lot because I feel like
guys like myself actually wouldn't have
a job or it not for the Gil Branson no
kuipers and the guys who came before me
so I respect him a lot I strongly
disagree with that take I think you can
watch Daniel he moves like Eli but
people are definitely over connecting
the fact that he was coached by David
Cutcliffe like Alec and I could have the
same linebackers coach and you could
tell the he's gonna be better than me
like it's it's just obvious so it
doesn't matter like we could you know
who coached you doesn't matter if you
don't have the skills so it's that time
I remember people thinking that Ryan
nasib was gonna be the first pick
because Doug Marrone draft you know
coached him so it's we overthink the
draft it should actually be like March
1st because you just have six weeks to
overthink stuff alright guys that is the
podcast let's think Alec again for
hanging out there yeah yeah definitely
appreciate that Conor and I will be
hanging out for a while here with our
live audience please don't forget watch
the bleacher report stream on Thursday
Friday and Saturday during the day and
also we will have podcasts recaps after
every round so Friday morning you get a
podcast Saturday morning you get a
podcast into Monday morning we'll be
back recap in the whole draft thanks
again to our sponsor manscaped big
believer in their product your boss will
thank you if you use it it really is
it's amazing so that's our show thank
you guys we'll talk to you real soon
thanks guys